atlanta's popping like that atlanta's
popping
wow the south is popping the south don't
put up with the same [ __ ] we got to
deal with mm-hmm
you like everywhere everywhere we go
it's thinking that's so different like
they
they laugh at us like la's so [ __ ]
ridiculous like newsome
shut down restaurants again he wants to
do a full lockdown soon
meanwhile think how preposterous this is
and i can't believe people put up with
it
meanwhile this this [ __ ] idiot's in
hawaii
yeah his kids are in private school
still going to school
so yeah we're locking down schools we're
locking on this it's like but he's not
living the life
he does he's living right it doesn't
affect him at all he goes i'm gonna take
a salary cut never took a salary cut
he's not affected at all by this so why
would you listen to a guy who's on top
of the mountain
trying to tell you what's like living at
the bottom of the mountain why would you
listen that [ __ ] idiot
he's trying to listen to his rules it's
not a dick it's insane yeah
and we've seen that lockdowns don't make
a difference
you have a better chance at getting
corona or catching corona
it's like small small gatherings with
the mask yep so the fact that we're like
you want to keep us separated it's
it's preposterous yeah borderline
malarkey
and it's funny it's fake is it is he is
he good on that word
malarkey yeah said word
survey says you said it it worked good
answers
i shocked a lot of people they're like
what the hell said i think we could kill
it on family feud
oh yeah you can see the americans are
putting up with it like
remember the cdc uh travel restrictions
oh yeah i saw the busiest day ever at
the airport during the pandemic was the
this past weekend people were flying to
see their families shout out to this
place
then you go on the then you go on the
news and they're like people are
traveling it's like yeah you [ __ ]
morons yeah they want to see their
family
like literally this whole year been a
waste what is i like and i won't say
that well i'm just tired of the mental
gymnastics of forests like
gymnastics i don't know
let's restart that again you said it
with your chest though that's good yeah
yeah
yeah you're confident i was gonna let it
slide yeah that's the hell that's the
best
i don't know where you're going you know
that's my field because i flub words all
the time i hope you just power through
it
i actually do it to the bones of use
yeah the blood look at look at him look
at him
what are we saying mental gymnastics
yeah of not knowing it's because we're
like in the gray area yeah in the gray
area and i'm tired of that like i watch
cnn and i watch fox news and i watch nbc
i don't know why i watch any of them i
know right they're all
everywhere all of them have an agenda
all of them have an agenda all of them
have one thing to do
it's all fair porn like it's all fair
media and notice like they're not saying
you don't tune in on there and they say
how great the vaccine is and
the f it's going to be dished out that's
why december 11th yeah they don't you
don't hear that do you
no you don't hear that has a 95 success
rate
you don't you don't hear that they have
over 300 million vaccines that they're
going to get to americans you don't hear
any of that well can you explain because
you don't hear them saying you don't him
fauci saying with this vaccine yeah
we'll be back to normal by march
do you see any of that because that's
not going to get ratings that's not what
the
news wants to do no raiding's putting
fair make sure you're locked at home
make sure you don't have thanksgiving
meanwhile every one of those
[ __ ] that's telling you that
including our bitch-ass governor is
having
is having thanksgiving is in hawaii is
flying
to on vacations is going to dinners yes
it's not
talking about he had to practice what he
preaches and all that when he got caught
with no man dude
you're talking about a real piece of
[ __ ] those people are the biggest
lowlifes
that we have to offer in america
politicians are the biggest piece of
[ __ ]
yeah well well since imagine imagine
that that's your goal
especially now in politics is that's
what you want to do you got to take
funding from [ __ ] up people you got to
do shady [ __ ] you got to rub his back
so you can get this yes it's the
dirtiest of all dirt
it's a mafia they're all mafia and they
all grandfather
people that they want in because they
have this agenda and they're going to
pay them under the table
to pass this law it's [ __ ] up dude
meanwhile
while he shuts down everyone and we
can't deal with another shutdown because
restaurants can go bankrupt
he's going to shut them down for three
weeks at least
for three weeks at least i got the order
and americans aren't putting up with it
and they're not getting bailed out or
anything
nope they don't give a [ __ ] so when
they're shutting down is it like
no outdoor seating no indoor scene just
taking it out and done
an article he said take and then there's
a guy there's a guy today i was watching
on the news being like we
literally if if he does intact the
lockdown like
we'll go out of business yeah like we
can't no and he's like me and
all the restaurants i see on this route
will all be gone
and nussan's like well sorry trying to
trying to make sure that
cove would there's no outbreaks we're
gonna it's the same [ __ ]
we get everyone gets it and it flattens
everyone gets it flat like it's
it's crazy that's so unfortunate i wanna
i wanna actually it's such a shame
it is i was reading and they said nusum
is only doing what
biden and camilla harry says because
he's he already solidified
his seat in the white house what did
that what does that mean i don't know
well he's one of the same so pelosi's
used to be his
uh aunt she was made i forget who
someone related to him
so that they they basically he's going
to do what puts them in
the best light he's on their team
there's two teams red and blue
he's all blue so he's going to run the
entire
california into the [ __ ] ground he
doesn't care as long
as he can just move on and hopefully run
for you know
the the president in the future yeah how
often is there voting for
governors well he's going to lose that
every four years his his uh approval
rates in the [ __ ]
yeah he's going to lose yeah what is
that uh what do you mean approval
so people don't like them yeah got it
people don't like him
and uh also how about cuomo wanna emmy
for the way he's handled the
the the [ __ ] corona probably up there
and emmy up there
i guess it's daytime news because he was
given updates on him killing old people
oh well i mean he had to say it like
that
that's what he did yeah hairline red
different
nuts
[Music]
owners fair they won't survive another
couple of 19 shutdowns and how crazy
they just don't care
sorry dude and they don't even bail them
out
i mean like it's like hey we're gonna
there's no like hey we're gonna shut you
down but we're gonna give
you x amount of money to help you during
this shutdown he's running california
like a dictatorship like he
is he puts down the law and we have to
like we
post a buy about like oh there's no
restaurants so who gets
even the world health organization came
out i was like man lockdowns are not you
guys aren't doing it
correct so they said that's doing it the
way it should be yeah like that's
exactly what we're supposed to do
all the only thing lockdown the only
thing lockdown i'm supposed to do
is to make sure hospitals don't get
overran make sure they're not
overcrowded
correct no hospital here is overcrowded
they've never been overcrowded not once
no not [ __ ] once my mom works at
season saw not
not like oh which one uh right there on
beverly hills oh really yeah the growth
and what she did it's not crowded right
not at all yeah i have so many friends
nurses doctors and like not nothing
never once a matter of fact hospitals
were shutting down
yeah because they didn't have enough
people weren't coming in for for
alternative surgeries so they had to
shut down
wow remember let's jump
i got mind control over deebo over noosa
what you saying
when he leave he'd be like shut up i'll
be quiet
leave me leave i'll be talking again i
keep talking how about that
when i get off stage at the lab factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what just run a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler we got a [ __ ]
together come on
i'm just saying dude grab that mic son